i can say almost everybody that i know
who has strong opinions about the
opposing side they also make assumptions
you've made a lot of assumptions you
yourself even in this recording if you
go back and listen to it you've made the
assumptions of whether how wealthy
people are how billionaires are whether
you've said people that make over three
hundred thousand dollars they're not as
happy as i would assume i said in
general this the science proves that no
no no so an assumption let me let me
parse this out for you so an assumption
would be to say about one person as an
individual yeah
but the scientific studies say this is
true for people in general you can't
pull out one person from that that would
be an assumption i'm going to call the
assumption cops to come and audit both
of us i'm going to say to all the
assumptions cops out there to all the
assumptions cops if i made assumptions
comment below give me the minute if dan
made assumptions hold us accountable put
it below